oppressive turkish President Erdogan is
saying that Donald Trump did great
by putting CNN reporter Jim Acosta in
his place during last week's insane
press conference this is the same
President Erdogan who once said he's
more and more against we Internet every
day this is the same Turkish president
who once called Hitler's Germany an
example of effective government
not exactly the instance I like to point
to when I want to talk about how
efficient and effective a government can
be and Johan reminded the audience that
Donald Trump you know he had this press
conference last week after first one
after being elected he didn't allow CNN
reporter Jim Acosta to ask a question
saying that it's it's CNN his fake news
I'm not allowing you to ask a question
and president Erdogan said look a
mistake done against Trump during his
press conference and Trump what that
group's reporter or columnist in place
Wow really a ringing endorsement from
yet another oppressive authoritarian
strong man for Donald Trump he's
collecting these endorsements one after
another yeah and I completely disagree
with the sentiment I think Trump not
wanting to answer a question or even
take a question from Jim Acosta yeah was
a sign of weakness it was like he was
running away from the confrontation yeah
clearly he couldn't even really handle
it and Rachel we are really seeing I
don't know that you know they use this
term a bro fest I don't know if that's
what we're seeing but Turkish leader Oda
Wan went on to say I believe we will we
will accelerate dialogue when mr. Trump
turns a takes office this is not one-way
praise because Donald Trump praised the
turkish President Erdogan for quote
turning the coup around I mean he is
kind of the father of censorship of
media and during the 2013 uprisings when
you turned on the television yeah
instead of seeing coverage of the
demonstrations you would see cooking
shows that's right it was Turkish
cooking face pretending nothing's going
on everything don't look out your window
keep your eye on the TV and how to how
to boil the garlic away right yes
because a lot of the owners business
interests are allied on the government
so they kind of steered cleared of
covering the demonstrations and then
there was the ban on Twitter so that
protesters couldn't organize yeah if
anything that should not be surprising I
know especially when Tom's talking about
making it easier to sue media outlets
libel lawsuits etc when when I heard you
on talked about putting a journalist in
its place I was thinking in Turkey isn't
putting a journalist in their place
either putting them in jail or killing
them I mean this is not exactly the guy
you want to be taking praise from when
it comes to handling media a ringing
endorsement the world diplomatic
community really coming to the support
of Donald Trump even Fox News reporter
Shepard Smith said that Trump shouldn't
be treating reporters like this
although Shepard Smith isn't exactly the
rule but rather the exception at Fox
News the headline is yet another
authoritarian leader of a country that
ranks among the worst in the world when
it comes to freedom of the press who has
been systematically silencing opposition
and demolishing democracy is standing up
pat for Trump against the quote biased
media yeah air Dhawan duterte Vladimir
Putin I mean these people should all
really just have a club of strongman
authoritarian types that Pat each other
on the back and some people will write
this off as hey politics makes strange
bedfellows doesn't mean anything about
Trump now this is a guy who appeals in
Trump to all the wrong people because of
what he says and what he promises to do
its authoritarian backing authoritarians
and Pat mentioned the Filipino president
Duterte story which I won't rehash for
you now Trump is the best he wins at
everything including getting the most
unusual endorsements I guess you can
talk about this with us on reddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t back
after this Warby Parker is offering a
free five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trial com slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers
over me and I like more than 30 seconds
to actually figure out whether I like
the glasses so with the Warby Parker
home Tryon I was able to pick five pairs
that I liked put them on in the comfort
of my own home pick the one I like the
most and then Warby Parker put my
prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses hi which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing